[Music]
taking that internship in a remote
mountain lab might not have been the
best idea pulling that lever with the
skull symbol just to see what it did
probably wasn't so smart either but now
is not the time for regrets because you
need to get away from these mutant
zombies fast with you are the janitor
the lab assistant and the old professor
you've gotten a head start but there's
only one way to safety across an old
rope bridge spanning a massive Gorge you
can dash across in a minute while the
lab assistant takes two minutes the
janitor is a bit slower and needs five
minutes and the professor takes a whole
ten minutes holding on to the ropes
every step of the way by the professor's
calculations the zombies will catch up
to you in just over 17 minutes so you
only have that much time to get everyone
across and cut the ropes
unfortunately the bridge can only hold
two people at a time to make matters
worse it's so dark out that you can
barely see and the old lantern you
grabbed on your way only illuminates a
tiny area can you figure out a way to
have everyone escape in time remember no
more than two people can cross the
bridge together anyone crossing must
either hold the lantern or stay right
next to it and any of you can safely
wait in the dark on either side of the
gorge most importantly everyone must be
safely across before the zombies arrive
otherwise the first zombie could step on
the bridge while people are still on it
finally there are no tricks to use here
you can't swing across use the bridge as
a raft or befriend the zombies
at first it might seem like no matter
what you do you're just a minute or two
short of time but there is a wick the
key is to minimize the time wasted by
the two slowest people by having them
cross together and because you'll need
to make a couple of return trips with
the lantern you'll want to have the
fastest people available to do so so you
and the lab assistant quickly run across
with the lantern though you have to slow
down a bit to match her pace after two
minutes both of you are across and you
as the quickest run back with the
lantern only three minutes have passed
so far so good
now comes the hard part the professor
and the janitor take the lantern and
cross together this takes them ten
minutes since the janitor has to slow
down for the old professor who keeps
muttering that he probably shouldn't
have given the zombies night vision by
the time they're across there are only
four minutes left and you're still stuck
on the wrong side of the bridge but
remember the lab assistant has been
waiting on the other side and she is the
second fastest of the group so she grabs
the lantern from the professor and runs
back across to you now with only two
minutes left the two of you make the
final crossing as you step on the far
side of the gorge you cut the ropes and
collapse the bridge behind you just in
the nick of time maybe next summer
you'll just stick to the library
you
[Music]